ottawa police have begun handing out
notices to protesters warning they'd be
receiving tickets and criminal charges
should they continue to refuse to leave
this is the ottawa police are handing
these out
oh well you know you can't be blocking
streets or assisting others
are you going to leave committing a
criminal offense
are you leaving am i leaving is this my
country
i pay taxes
no i'll stay wherever i want
and i support the truckers 100 no a
thousand percent there's different
perspectives on that
for your people like when it comes down
to well then if you
this isn't going against the law it's
using the war act to go against it's not
the war on the war yeah well just
because it's renaming emergencies right
yeah it's the same thing no different
do you mind telling me how the two are
different you'd have to ask your lawyer
okay
just do what's right voice when it comes
time to do it
okay we're out you want to look up your
job
and you don't want to
give me the name
you can go down to catherine
[Music]
what does that mean are you going to
leave
no not yet not yet no planning to leave
you planning to leave oh no no but yes
probably if the government
i think
the
the situation
changed uh slowly because a lot of uh
performance removed the past wax pass
and removed
i think the the province understand it
have a lot of canadian citizen
don't want restriction now
and i think for this reason i think
since few days
the the country moved and
now the the prime minister
is uh not awake now
we need
probably
the prime minister change
in the few days in a few weeks
[Music]
thank you all canadians should be
surprised
no matter your political opinions that
the federal government has resorted to
such an extreme and authoritarian
measure like the emergencies act
and that the government wants to use
force against a peaceful demonstration
we are peaceful demonstrators
engaging in lawful advocacy
protest and dissent
the federal government emergency order
clearly states that this protest is
allowed to continue as long as the
protesters are peaceful
the government is trying to order the
police
to use force against canadian citizens
who are peacefully demonstrating
as canadians we cannot allow this to
happen
when did they give you that
doesn't change
[Music]
you